let's talk about desantis and see where
we're where we're ahead in this country
desantis defends math textbook rejection
as dems seek proof of critical race
theory lessons florida education
department officials have not yet
provided examples from the textbook
textbooks deemed impermis impermissible
but on monday released the list of books
that failed to make the cut so
apparently
santa's defended it we want kids to
learn to think so they get the right
answer descendants told reporters the
florida department of education on
friday rejected some 54 math books from
state classrooms a move that drew
national attention when desantis claimed
that proposals from publishing companies
contained lessons on indoctrinating
concepts like race essentialism the move
was just the latest example of
republicans including desantis
scrutinizing what students are learning
blah blah okay here's the question
if the math books
don't have critical race theory in them
why are they bent out of shape they're
getting removed if it's just a math book
where it's like two plus two is four
then why why would they be mad about
that they'd be like oh i guess do we
sell a math book that says two plus two
equals four then why do we care if you
remove that one this is really
interesting because it is possible that
they're not actually teaching critical
race theory oh let me turn myself up um
and what they're doing is teaching a
form of praxis which is where critical
theory isn't everything it doesn't have
to be explicit it underlies everything
i've seen some of these math problems i
think it was matt walsh earlier today
who was reading some of these questions
about maya angelou and all the stuff
that went in on her life all this racism
she stood up to it's a math problem
you're supposed to be solving x and y
and a and b and all this stuff but
they're rolling into it all these ideas
so that they can say
we're not teaching critical race theory
this is practice we've talked about this
before this is critical race applied
right so an example would be
those old math problems where it's like
a train leaves detroit traveling 500
miles an hour and a train leaves
pittsburgh traveling at 50 miles an hour
and blah blah blah and then um you know
that's a math problem what they're doing
in these is they're like johnny is a
young white man who's 15 year 15 years
old and he gets stopped by the police
three times in one month but jerome is a
young black man who gets stopped by the
police 2 000 times in one month what
percentage of stops were
and then you're like okay we get it
that's what they're doing yeah i
honestly think it if anything it doesn't
go far enough i we as far as desantis's
move here
uh i had to go pick up one of my kids
from i have one kid in public school and
the rest of mine are homeschooled but uh
i had to go pick her up
and there was a a class the kids must
have been maybe seven years old and all
across the wall is the you know rainbow
flags and uh trans flag now nothing said
you know anything about but but the
coloring is all the right coloring you
know and there's like little sneaky
words you know like sharing is carrying
like care bears type stuff and this is
in a tiny town in in idaho in the
mountains by though i mean tiny that's
so it's everywhere and it's it's like
being pumped into these kids brains i
actually think like that's why colors
are so important you know kids like
latch on to that stuff and it's very
visually appealing for them so when it's
broadcast in their faces all the time
you don't have to have an explicit
message in there the message is like in
the image i still remember an image like
in fourth grade on my wall of the of a
horn like a trumpet playing music and it
showed the sound waves coming out like
this like round uh sorry if you're
listening you're not able to see but
then then the teacher came in one day i
was like actually the sound waves are
actually like this and they changed the
image of to a sine wave and that was
that sticks with me today that was like
35 years ago or something crazy
imagery is the most one of the most
powerful ways to teach a child anything
sound imagery smell those kind of things
yeah sensory stuff there are a bunch of
these videos that are coming out and
starting to expose what these teachers
are doing one of them is the um
like a gender flow chart almost yeah and
there's it's from libsap tick-tock i saw
this
where the teacher is like you start with
your
your sexuality and then you can go as
far as you want towards male or female
and then you come down to your identity
and it can be different and it's like
it's not
the thing is
if you tell a kid
trans people exist
gay people exist it's like okay i get it
you're telling them they exist if you
give them a card and tell them to draw
on a scale
where they are now you're you're
actually not just telling them exist now
you're doing some kind of litmus test
for them and their identity
and what happens then
if these kids feel like they're not
going to fit in if they go with the
bland gray flag the the siz flag they've
been showing kids is just black and
white
so why would a kid pick that one why
would the kid want to be the you know
boring no you can be fun and exciting
here do these things and so these kids
don't understand oppression they don't
understand civil rights these are young
kids between you know uh five years old
and nine years old they're being told
just to draw how they feel and they're
like whatever don't you think they're
going after them for because at that age
they don't understand sexuality at all
they don't have you know they're not
they're prepubescent and all this so if
you go after them then and you like
start talking to them about sexual
orientation of course like johnny and
jack are gonna say that they like each
other more because girls are stupid and
icky or whatever so then when they do
start to develop actual hormones and
feelings you're just like adding layers
of confusion because now they're getting
all the you know testosterone's flowing
they're like well i thought i liked you
know jack it turns out maybe jill's all
right you know i've i've heard some
horror stories
from these are coming out of
conservative states where like someone's
kid said that they thought they were pan
and their parent was like why do you
think you're pan and they're like
because i like everybody and they're
like you you like everybody that means
you want to kiss them and and their
daughter was like no
and they're friendly
yeah i just mean like i want to be
friends with them and like that's not
what that means they're lying to those
kids i'm not saying it's every classroom
but certainly that is happening because
these kids don't know what that means
and there's no way it gets to that level
of teaching that they don't know that
they're confusing them and that's the
worst part about it is that it's being
obfuscated intentionally uh partially
because they know the kids aren't old
enough to really process what that means
and partially just everything that you
don't say is everything every is every
bit as important as what you choose to
say what you leave out says almost more
about it than what you put in and that's
that's terrifying to me
yeah well i think it's i think reality
is yeah these these teachers are
indoctrinating kids and then the media
is doing everything in its power to to
push back so ibra max candy recently
came out and said that oh no they're
grooming kids to be white supremacists
and it's like wow it's working
if he's got to come out and try and do
that the messaging has worked you've got
candy trying to retake the word groomer
because they're grooming kids it ain't
going to work buddy no did you cover the
the first grade teacher who like told
like told the first grade class that
when when babies are born that they just
get the doctor just guesses whether it's
a boy or a girl oh yeah i think we
talked about that talk about that i
don't remember that they just guess they
just that he's just told because doctors
guesses it's what happens there's
another video from libs of tiktok where
the doctor's basically saying that where
it's like it's typically based on their
their you know their their genetics
their genitals but usually it's just
their genitals and sometimes they're
wrong
it's like
well
sometimes as in like you know point zero
seven zero yeah percent of the time yeah
but that's why ethics is so important
science can only get you so far you can
only you can only look at pieces and
parts and decide your final answer but i
mean that's i think maybe the
conversation about ethics and emotions
has gone kind of too far in one
direction where it's like if you feel
like you're different sex then then
that's
reality because we have not been having
much talk about emotions so this is like
the the hammer's coming swinging back i
feel like society's really detached from
its emotional self how often do you see
people cry how often do you see people
publicly acknowledging their suffering
well i mean you could kids that used to
have
even though they weren't living on a
farm or whatever they used to know
people that were farmers they had a
grandfather that was a farmer or you
know an uncle or whatever and so they
were involved with animal husbandry and
that stuff at a younger age and you
don't have to explain like kids ranch
kids don't get birds in the bees talks
because they've been breeding animals
you know being
they've been around animals who were
being bred since they were very very
young so there's an implicit
understanding there like dad doesn't
have to sit down and say you know when a
mama be loves a daddy b you know it's
like they've been seeing stud horses and
mares out in the pasture chickens
chickens yeah yeah like we got we got
chicken city and i was thinking about
this too um
a lot of people talk about how their
kids will watch chicken city their dogs
their cats obviously watch it too but
chicken cities become this massive
success thank you everybody but no in
all seriousness the uh you know you'll
get kids watching with their parents and
they'll be like i want to feed the
chickens and so they'll put the five
bucks in the food comes down
and then you'll see the rooster mount
the hen and you know do his roaster
business
explain that well i mean it's this this
chicken city is overtly over the top
family friendly chickens do these things
like if you want to teach your kids
about farms and petting zoos you're
going to watch that stuff happen now
maybe if your kids never been exposed to
that you're going to have that
conversation but to your point that i
was thinking about this earlier i was
like
kid who grows up on a goat farm she's
never going to have that question
because they're like a little kid
watching the goats do their thing you
know what i mean
yeah it's it's just totally true and the
chicken thing might be a little bit hard
because then it's like wait so we're
eating chicken babies that's what we're
eating yeah
oh wow yeah yup every day those eggs
come out it's not necessarily a baby
yeah right but uh you don't eat the
chicks you gotta wait for them to grow
that's where you get to meet do you guys
have a farm yeah do you did you explain
to your kids about like we're raising
the animals we're gonna eat the animals
or anything like that oh i mean
no
i don't know just kind of happens my in
fact my little sister when she was
she was probably 10 years old or so
maybe not she was younger than that
seven or eight years old anyway she come
come home from school and got off the
school bus and i was out feeding her
something and i came around she and i
just come in the back door and i hear
you hey mom i'm hungry i want to eat bob
it was this it was this steer that she'd
named bob you know and she loved the
steer or whatever but she's like
whatever's food food
he's cute and everything but we're going
to eat them so i not notice it's another
one of those things just kind of
implicit i don't think imagine being bob
yeah right
i know that name do they do they like uh
argue against naming them for that
reason
no i'm i mean
uh my stepfather used to hate it but i
like for me personally it doesn't bother
me at all like yesterday i was at my
in-laws uh getting ready to come to
easter and then getting ready to come
out here and as soon as i left we had a
one of our heifers calved you know my
wife comes home she's like oh look at
this so cute you know i mean thank
goodness i didn't have to pull it or
anything but you know she's talking
about how cute these little angus calves
are or whatever and i'm like yeah i get
it and then you know the kids are
hearing her talk like that but they
never
they never have a problem you know
eating like they know it's a cow
from the beginning with that you would
just know from the tiniest age yeah i
think you're just closer to it or
something this is this is interesting
because we we've asked many times like
who would who was going to survive
better in the apocalypse or who was more
likely to survive a conservative rural
or urban liberal and a lot it's like no
one thinks the urban liberals are going
to make it but this is a really good
point we don't we we've not brought up
it's that
people who grow up in rural areas are
more likely to have been exposed at a
young age to slaughtering a pig or a
chicken to eat like you know i want to
eat bob
people in the city are going to be like
i have to do what with the knife and
then what do i do with those things
they're not going to want to do it they
want to walk in a supermarket where
there's just pink slime
they can just you know cook and eat it
we had a farm my dad my grandfather's
grandpa's a cousin at a farm northeast
ohio we would go out there alvin uncle
alvin and cousin alvin and then we see
the the whole the thing hanging upside
down like the cattle thing just all the
blood all the skin ripped off and it's
like wow wow and they i don't think i
ever watched him butcher it up and i
never saw him kill it i did see my dad
kill some kill a groundhog and that was
well he he
family friendly he wounded the groundhog
and it escaped and i just saw the trail
of blood and it was really disturbing i
thought why why hunt if you're not gonna
like why would you destroy houses yeah i
you know there's always a reason about
it but it was pretty tragic to see it
get wounded and get away because i was
like what's gonna happen and he was like
well i was gonna die in a hole somewhere
good eating yeah
yeah the thing about groundhogs is that
they knock trees down they can destroy
houses they can destroy foundations so i
was reading about it and apparently
there are some places where if you
actually catch the groundhog you have to
kill it
interesting
because
you can be liable for the damages it
caused after you've caught it i did not
know that crazy right yeah well like
imagine imagine you catch it and they're
like oh i don't want to hurt the little
thing so you just bring it to the edge
of your property and let it go and go to
your neighbor's house and knocks a tree
down they're going to be like you you
release that thing on me yeah someone
mentioned that about mice or like if you
don't do something with them they will
come back and they'll get worse and i
was going to say that i think that maybe
one of the best things about living on a
ranch is that you can teach your kids
about the circle of life like if
something does crawl in a hole and die
then other things come along and eat it
it becomes part of the soil it's all
part of like growing plants and all this
really it's actually really a neat cycle
that i think kids would benefit from
knowing about these things are hard
because we have led such like kind of
privileged and cushioned lives we can go
to the store and get these little pink
things that are they're chicken where
did it come from we don't know milk
grows on the shelves it's absolute
insanity we have no connection to the
things we eat it's a good opportunity to
teach kids about that kind of cycle
really important would you butcher at
the farm yeah i butcher all her stuff
yeah i do yeah i do my own butchering
yeah
in fact that this this discussion made
me think of
my friend shanna she always says that
cows are friends and steers are food
which is true you know like cows have
more babies and you eat the steers or
keep your replacement heifers and sell
some off and so anyway so there is kind
of a little bit of bifurcation that's
worth talking about like the cows
themselves are actually in a
occupy a different place it's because
you keep them comfortable so they have
healthy babies and they produce good
milk well i mean you want to keep them
all comfortable ideally because you want
you know you want as much pound on the
animal as you can when you go to
butcher and if they're stressed out the
meat can be bad right
uh yeah i mean really stress is more
just like they'll have a harder time
gaining weight at least that's been yeah
now like if you're hunting
there yeah if you if you
if you wound something it's going to get
a hit of neuroepinephrine and then your
meat is going to be more tense and
stiffer or uh tough
wow so yeah so when you're hunting you
want to you want the animal to go to be
like in the head just down yeah well
yeah i killed as quickly as possible
like
and then there are some arguments people
will make that
uh
like an arrow through and i've seen it a
bunch of times and
an arrow through the actual like boiler
room with the vitals
the animal
almost i mean they'll run off but you
can tell they have no idea what happened
you know they're just like then they
just die oh wow so oh okay so then they
don't get the
there's not a big loud sound associated
with it it's just a sharp pain and then
they're done because it's an arrow
yeah a broad head you know it's just a
clean cut and the bow doesn't make a lot
of noise and so i've heard this argument
i don't know how much i don't know how
much like bro science is going on there
but i mean it's i think it's a it's a
viable argument i think so like when you
when when they realize they're in danger
they tense up and then the muscle
becomes stiff and hard and then you try
to eat it it's like you get it yeah i
think the big hit just the big hit of
adrenaline yeah you know going through
and stiffens mop yeah
and then you know of course like if you
hit something in the guts or whatever
then that's a whole nother you kind of
see that with factory farming when they
lead the cattle into the bolt thing
where they're going to put the bolt in
their head and then you watch the one
behind it here the one in front of it
die and it they freak out sure so that's
got to be affecting the final me the
meat it's i mean i feel like i'm almost
disassociated i don't know i have i'm a
weird empathetic creature happy cows man
yeah happy cows happy but cows aren't
raised for beef is it their dairy and
then what the steers are the beef cattle
uh cat yeah yeah yeah so cows are kind
of yeah cows are the females right and
they're gonna reproduce you know so you
turn your bulls in depending on your
setup you turn your bulls in for some
people leave them in all the time but
you know you tune your bulls in for x
amount of months and then you know you
pull your bulls out and then like right
now at home most of us are calvin or
almost done kevin which is just having
the babies you know
and then yeah
you'll win cows and calves you know
later on and that's when they'll go to
auction you know how long does it take
for a calf to grow up
to speak on either food or it depends on
your setup whether you're running a cow
calf operation or you're running a feed
operation or just like buying ballers or
steers and uh it depends on what you're
doing but like let's just say
just for around about let's just say
eight months ish and then you go to
auction or keep your replacement so if
if i wanted milk right and i bought day
one just born calf how long until i can
you know work with the ball to make
start producing milk and getting the
baby and everything i see uh usually
breed heifers around two years old two
years yeah can they are there any are
they able to in inbreed like chickens
uh
well i mean you castrate all the
the bulls right so you just have
oh i see what you're saying dad yes
exactly
uh yeah i mean you try to avoid that
where you can but sure but some people
will laundry you castrate the bulls
well the bull calves
you know so when you don't want them
because you only want one to be breeding
with them or what yeah well yeah don't
you don't want a nine-month-old or so
bull calf out there breeding your
heifers or whatever right right right
plus you know just makes better meat so
there's like right so there's specific
specific bowls will be
left not cat straight castrated right
yeah you'll pull those out and put them
in their own pen and then those are the
studs
yeah basically yeah that's a great name
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the tim cast irl
podcast and there's a massive library to
check out so again go to timcast.com or
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
we'll see you all there